[Music]
I'm obviously an extreme what I found
when I came out of the closet as trans
because I say I always knew I was trans
and I think that's not true of all trans
people it's not what defines us but it
is true of a lot of us so in part I
think I lost I sometimes feel like many
of us do a lost childhood that I didn't
get to fully be myself but on the other
hand I also feel like I was able to
frequently be myself because I was never
in the closet to myself and it was
something that I always found a little
space literally closets sometimes to be
myself growing up in the valley and my
dad started a software company
I learned to code and the first reason I
learned to code the first thing I did
with it was create I had a I wrote a
little thing of code to password protect
the file it was like really early days
away my dad had bought a computer and we
wish it was assembled and it was the
first private space that I had with
sisters and cousins and my mom as snow
Zee as sheep as we all knew she was
there was no way I could have a diary
but the first place I could write was
this space that I knew like no one would
read but me and that for me yeah I think
a lot of trans people work in tech
because as kids it was the place we
could be ourselves and but what I think
I found when I came out of the closet
the biggest fear that once my wife
accepted me instead of wanted a divorce
and she understood I didn't I actually
have always been attracted to girls and
that was really hard on the whole gender
I orientation and sexual orientation
and like if I could whisper back to
myself as a teenager you can be a girl
and like girls but it was all so
confusing through all of this and for
her there's no narratives and I think if
you accept more than anything for I
think I think there's a simple I've been
thinking about this a lot and I think
that there's a there's when we are
living in a paradigm which is our
current one where we are trying to find
the role already existing that we fit
into I think when we try to exist in
modern times in that paradigm it causes
a tremendous stress and anxiety because
that's humans it turns out that very few
of us that so perfectly I think coming
out as trans what has been beautiful for
me is to see that while I get to meet a
lot of people who identify as trans what
I meet either what I mean overwhelmingly
people identify with trans people with
this sense of not fitting into these
things and I see with for kids and all
of them little from twelve to one and a
half are you gonna grow up to be a
firearm men or or you can be the
president don't forget to dream big and
the biggest dream we can put out there
for them it's the president they asked
from middle school for kids to think
about their specialty and it's like how
could you know you don't know you won't
yeah I think the smartest people don't
know what their thing is when they're 70
but the biggest dream should be you're
gonna invent something we don't know yet
and when you look at humanity
everyone who's alive picks from the
existing narrative roles that we've been
given and they used to be terribly
primitive but they still are shockingly
permitted from where I think we can get
to quite rapidly if we accept this
different paradigm
where the goal is to create a new role
it's to build a new narrative that we
have hundreds of years of expanding
narratives before we've exhausted what
it could be mean to be human people
don't talk about happiness very often
and happiness is the most important
thing in our lives it's the most
valuable metric of our lives is how
happy we were
everything else is noise I went to Costa
Rica when I was younger and we met this
was deep in the jungle and OSA Peninsula
we but this shaman who was really
amazing
he knew the jungle and all the bird
calls really incredible person and he
and I very much connected and a little
moment that even 15 or 20 years how long
it's been so always sticks with me as he
said listen see this flower and it was a
gorgeous complicated jungle flower ESA's
if you love it then you'll understand it
because you'll pay attention and seal
and if you hate it then you'll only have
that thin little photo of it you won't
ever understand so when you think of
your boxes is that simple what are they
what do you love to do what made you
happy and those are the things that your
soul are fighting to find again